welcome back to las vegas now want to
check out the best
that nevada has to offer try it on atv
we take a ride with adventure time tours
and rentals
what we do at adventure time rentals is
pretty much offer people a safe way to
go out and explore our backyards
we do it on state-of-the-art glare
side-by-side razors
we've got all the safety features to
allow you to take your family
100 miles out in the middle of desert
and you'll find us just outside of
polaris can-am honda world
80 of our renters this is their first
time in a razor
so they don't really know what to expect
they're pretty much
driving just like a car with an amazing
suspension system
we've got them all equipped with gps
satellite tracking
satellite communication devices our gps
tablets have
pre-recorded routes that allow people to
explore many different options and
do it with confidence that they're gonna
return home safe with their family
[Music]
a lot of people when they drive by
mesquite have no idea the terrain
and the different options that we have
and to be able to do it in a safe
environment
provided with adventure time rentals is
really just an amazing experience for
our customers okay so we've got the
grand canyon parashant national monument
right in our backyard
we've got gold butte national monument
right in our backyard
and we've got endless riding out in the
dry desert washes as well
my favorite part is just exploring the
wilderness
you know like i said grand canyon
parashant national monument you can
actually get up into some
ponderosa pine tree forest going from
the desert environment
all the way up and you can do it safely
as well
we are taking your safety serious we've
upped our cleaning procedures
every machine gets completely
disinfected with our medical grade
disinfectant our helmets
all of our safety gears completely
sanitized in between
every adventure on top of that we
honestly are
providing the safest most enjoyable way
to socially distance yourself
and allowing you to get out of these
crowds take your family out into a
safe environment and show them god's
earth
so gang we just wanted to let you all
know that players can m honda world
we do not only offer rentals we also
offer sales
service parts and we are open and we are
safe
we are offering the best experience the
most enjoyable social distancing that
you can do
we do rent seven days a week as well so
join us at adventuretimerentals.com for
either
further questions or availability so
awesome give adventure time tours and
rentals a call at 702 702-672-6161 or
visit their website
adventuretimerentals.com
rocky i could see you hanging over there
jc
all right